We only have four more lectures
left, and what Professor Demaine
and I have decided to do is give
two series of lectures on sort
of advanced topics.
So, today at Wednesday we're
going to talk about parallel
algorithms, algorithms where you
have more than one processor
whacking away on your problem.
And this is a very hot topic
right now because all of the
chip manufacturers are now
producing so-called multicore
processors where you have more
than one processor per chip.
So, knowing something about
that is good.
The second topic we're going to
cover is going to be caching,
and how you design algorithms
for systems with cache.
Right now, we've sort of
program to everything as if it
were just a single level of
memory, and for some problems
that's not an entirely realistic
model.
You'd like to have some model
for how the caching hierarchy
works, and how you can take
advantage of that.
And there's been a lot of
research in that area as well.
So, both of those actually turn
out to be my area of research.
So, this is actually fun for
me.
Actually, most of it's fun
anyway.
So, today we'll talk about
parallel algorithms.
And the particular topic,
it turns out that there are
lots of models for parallel
algorithms, and for parallelism.
And it's one of the reasons
that, whereas for serial
algorithms, most people sort of
have this basic model that we've
been using.
It's sometimes called a random
access machine model,
which is what we've been using
to analyze things,
whereas in the parallel space,
there's just a huge number of
models, and there is no general
agreement on what is the best
model because there are
different machines that are made
with different configurations,
etc.
and people haven't,
sort of, agreed on,
even how parallel machines
should be organized.
So, we're going to deal with a
particular model,
which goes under the rubric of
dynamic multithreading,
which is appropriate for the
multicore machines that are now
being built for shared memory
programming.
It's not appropriate for what's
called distributed memory
programs particularly because
the processors are able to
access things.
And for those,
you need more involved models.
And so, let me start just by
giving an example of how one
would write something.
I'm going to give you a program
for calculating the nth
Fibonacci number in this model.
This is actually a really bad
algorithm that I'm going to give
you because it's going to be the
exponential time algorithm,
whereas we know from week one
or two that you can calculate
the nth Fibonacci number and how
much time?
Log n time.
So, this is too exponentials
off what you should be able to
get, OK, two exponentials off.
OK, so here's the code.
OK, so this is essentially the
pseudocode we would write.
And let me just explain a
little bit about,
we have a couple of key words
here we haven't seen before:
in particular,
spawn and sync.
OK, so spawn,
this basically says that the
subroutine that you're calling,
you use it as a keyword before
a subroutine,
that it can execute at the same
time as its parent.
So, here, what we say x equals
spawn of n minus one,
we immediately go onto the next
statement.
And now, while we're executing
fib of n minus one,
we can also be executing,
now, this statement which
itself will spawn something off.
OK, and we continue,
and then we hit the sync
statement.
And, what sync says is,
wait until all children are
done.
OK, so it says once you get to
this point, you've got to wait
until everything here has
completed before you execute the
x plus y because otherwise
you're going to try to execute
the calculation of x plus y
without having computed it yet.
OK, so that's the basic
structure.
What this describes,
notice in here we never said
how many processors or anything
we are running on.
OK, so this actually is just
describing logical parallelism
--
-- not the actual parallelism
when we execute it.
And so, what we need is a
scheduler, OK,
to determine how to map this
dynamically, unfolding execution
onto whatever processors you
have available.
OK, and so, today actually
we're going to talk mostly about
scheduling.
OK, and then,
next time we're going to talk
about specific application
algorithms, and how you analyze
them.
OK, so you can view the actual
multithreaded computation.
If you take a look at the
parallel instruction stream,
it's just a directed acyclic
graph, OK?
So, let me show you how that
works.
So, normally when we have an
instruction stream,
I look at each instruction
being executed.
If I'm in a loop,
I'm not looking at it as a
loop.
I'm just looking at the
sequence of instructions that
actually executed.
I can do that just as a chain.
Before I execute one
instruction, I have to execute
the one before it.
Before I execute that,
I've got to execute the one
before it.
At least, that's the
abstraction.
If you've studied processors,
you know that there are a lot
of tricks there in figuring out
instruction level parallelism,
and how you can actually make
that serial instruction stream
actually execute in parallel.
But what we are going to be
mostly talking about is the
logical parallelism here,
and what we can do in that
context.
So, in this DAG,
the vertices are threads,
which are maximal sequences of
instructions not containing --
-- parallel control.
And by parallel control,
I just mean spawn,
sync, and return from a spawned
procedure.
So, let's just mark the,
so the vertices are threads.
So, let's just mark what the
vertices are here,
OK, what the threads are here.
So, when we enter the function
here, we basically execute up to
the point where,
basically, here,
let's call that thread A where
we are just doing a sequential
execution up to either returning
or starting to do the spawn,
fib of n minus one.
So actually,
thread A would include the
calculation of n minus one right
up to the point where you
actually make the subroutine
jump.
That's thread A.
Thread B would be the stuff
that you would do,
executing from fib of,
sorry, B would be from the,
right.
We'd go up to the spawn.
So, we've done the spawn.
I'm really looking at this.
So, B would be up to the spawn
of y.
OK, spawn of fib of n minus two
to compute y,
and then we'd have essentially
an empty thread.
So, I'll ignore that for now,
but really then we have after
the sync up to the point that we
get to the return of x plus y.
So basically,
we're just looking at maximal
sequences of instructions that
are all serial.
And every time I do a parallel
instruction, OK,
spawn or a sync,
or return from it,
that terminates the current
thread.
OK, so we can look at that as a
bunch of small threads.
So those of you who are
familiar with threads from Java
threads, or POSIX threads,
OK, so-called P threads,
those are sort of heavyweight
static threads.
This is a much lighter weight
notion of thread,
OK, that we are using in this
model.
OK, so these are the vertices.
And now, let me map out a
little bit how this works,
so we can where the edges come
from.
So, let's imagine we're
executing fib of four.
So, I'm going to draw a
horizontal oval.
That's going to correspond to
the procedure execution.
And, in this procedure,
there are essentially three
threads.
We start out with A,
so this is our initial thread
is this guy here.
And then, when he executes a
spawn, OK, he's going to execute
a spawn, we are going to create
a new procedure,
and he's going to execute a new
A recursively within that
procedure.
But at the same time,
we're also going to be,
now, aloud to go on and execute
B in the parent,
we have parallelism here when I
do a spawn.
OK, and so there's an edge
here.
This edge we are going to call
a spawn edge,
and this is called a
continuation edge because it's
just simply continuing the
procedure execution.
OK, now at this point,
this guy, we now have two
things that can execute at the
same time.
Once I've executed A,
I now have two things that can
execute.
OK, so this one,
for example,
may spawn another thread here.
Oh, so this is fib of three,
right?
And this is now fib of two.
OK, so he spawns another guy
here, and simultaneously,
he can go on and execute B
here, OK, with a continued edge.
And B, in fact,
can also spawn at this point.
OK, and this is now fib of two
also.
And now, at this point,
we can't execute C yet here
even though I've spawned things
off.
And the reason is because C
won't execute until we've
executed the sync statement,
which can't occur until A and B
have both been executed,
OK?
So, he just sort of sits there
waiting, OK, and a scheduler
can't try to schedule him.
Or if he does,
then nothing's going to happen
here, OK?
So, we can go on.
Let's see, here we could call
fib of one.
The fib of one is only going to
execute an A statement here.
OK, of course it can't continue
here because A is the only
thing, when I execute fib of
one, if we look at the code,
it never executes B or C.
OK, and similarly here,
this guy here to do fib of one.
OK, and this guy,
I guess, could execute A here
of fib of one.
OK, and maybe now this guy
calls his another fib of one,
and this guy does another one.
This is going to be fib of
zero, right?
I keep drawing that arrow to
the wrong place,
OK?
And now, once these guys
return, well,
let's say these guys return
here, I can now execute C.
But I can't execute with them
until both of these guys are
done, and that guy is done.
So, you see that we get a
synchronization point here
before executing C.
And then, similarly here,
now that we've executed this
and this, we can now execute
this guy here.
And so, those returns go to
there.
Likewise here,
this guy can now execute his C,
and now once both of those are
done, we can execute this guy
here.
And then we are done.
This is our final thread.
So, I should have labeled also
that when I get one of these
guys here, that's a return edge.
So, the three types of edges
are spawn, return,
and continuation.
OK, and by describing it in
this way, I essentially get a
DAG that unfolds.
So, rather than having just a
serial execution trace,
I get something where I have
still some serial dependencies.
There are still some things
that have to be done before
other things,
but there are also things that
can be done at the same time.
So how are we doing?
Yeah, question?
Is every spawn were covered by
a sync, effectively,
yeah, yeah, effectively.
There's actually a null thread
that gets executed in there,
which I hadn't bothered to
show.
But yes, basically you would
then not have any parallelism,
OK, because you would spawn it
off, but then you're not doing
anything in the parent.
So it's pretty much the same,
yeah, as if it had executed
serially.
Yep, OK, so you can see that
basically what we had here in
some sense is a DAG embedded in
a tree.
OK, so you have a tree that's
sort of the procedure structure,
but in their you have a DAG,
and that DAG can actually get
to be pretty complicated.
OK, now what I want to do is
now that we understand that
we've got an underlying DAG,
I want to switch to trying to
study the performance attributes
of a particular DAG execution,
so looking at performance
measures.
So, the notation that we'll use
is we'll let T_P be the running
time of whatever our computation
is on P processors.
OK, so, T_P is,
how long does it take to
execute this on P processors?
Now, in general,
this is not going to be just a
particular number,
OK, because I can have
different scheduling disciplines
would lead me to get numbers for
T_P, OK?
But when we talk about the
running time,
we'll still sort of use this
notation, and I'll try to be
careful as we go through to make
sure that there's no confusion
about what that means in
context.
There are a couple of them,
though, which are fairly well
defined.
One is based on this.
One is T_1.
So, T_1 is the running time on
one processor.
OK, so if I were to execute
this on one processor,
you can imagine it's just as if
I had just gotten rid of the
spawn, and syncs,
and everything,
and just executed it.
That will give me a particular
running time.
We call that running time on
one processor the work.
It's essentially the serial
time.
OK, so when we talk about the
work of a computation,
we just been essentially a
serial running time.
OK, the other measure that ends
up being interesting is what we
call T infinity.
OK, and this is the critical
pathlength, OK,
which is essentially the
longest path in the DAG.
So, for example,
if we look at the fib of four
in this example,
it has T of one equal to,
so let's assume we have unit
time threads.
I know they're not unit time,
but let's just imagine,
for the purposes of
understanding this,
that every thread costs me one
unit of time to execute.
What would be the work of this
particular computation?
17, right, OK,
because all we do is just add
up three, six,
nine, 12, 13,
14, 15, 16, 17.
So, the work is 17 in this case
if it were unit time threads.
In general, you would add up
how many instructions or
whatever were in there.
OK, and then T infinity is the
longest path.
So, this is the longest
sequence.
It's like, if you had an
infinite number of processors,
you still can't just do
everything at once because some
things have to come before other
things.
But if you had an infinite
number of processors,
as many processors as you want,
what's the fastest you could
possibly execute this?
A little trickier.
Seven?
So, what's your seven?
So, one, two,
three, four,
five, six, seven,
eight, yeah,
eight is the longest path.
So, the work and the critical
path length, as we'll see,
are key attributes of any
computation.
And abstractly,
and this is just for [the
notes?], if they're unit time
threads.
OK, so we can use these two
measures to derive lower bounds
on T_P for P that fall between
one and infinity,
OK?
OK, so the first lower bound we
can derive is that T_P has got
to be at least T_1 over P.
OK, so why is that a lower
bound?
Yeah?
But if I have P processors,
and, OK, and why would I have
this lower bound?
OK, yeah, you've got the right
idea.
So, but can we be a little bit
more articulate about it?
So, that's right,
so you want to use all of
processors.
If you could use all of
processors, why couldn't I use
all the processors,
though, and have T_P be less
than this?
Why does it have to be at least
as big as T_1 over P?
I'm just asking for a little
more precision in the answer.
You've got exactly the right
idea, but I need a little more
precision if we're going to
persuade the rest of the class
that this is the lower bound.
Yeah?
Yeah, that's another way of
looking at it.
If you were to serialize the
computation, OK,
so whatever things you execute
on each step,
you do P of them,
and so if you serialized it,
somehow then it would take you
P steps to execute one step of a
P way, a machine with P
processors.
So then, OK,
yeah?
OK, maybe a little more
precise.
David?
Yeah, good, so let me just
state this a little bit.
So, P processors,
so what are we relying on?
P processors can do,
at most, P work in one step,
right?
So, in one step they do,
at most P work.
They can't do more than P work.
And so, if they can do,
at most P work in one step,
then if the number of steps
was, in fact,
less than T_1 over P,
they would be able to do more
than T_1 work in P steps.
And, there's only T_1 work to
be done.
OK, I just stated that almost
as badly as all the responses I
got.
[LAUGHTER] OK,
P processors can do,
at most, P work in one step,
right?
So, if there's T_1 work to be
done, the number of steps is
going to be at least T_1 over P,
OK?
There we go.
OK, it wasn't that hard.
It's just like,
I've got a certain amount of,
I've got T_1 work to do.
I can knock off,
at most, P on every step.
How many steps?
Just divide.
OK, so it's going to have to be
at least that amount.
OK, good.
The other lower bound is T_P is
greater than or equal to T
infinity.
Somebody explain to me why that
might be true.
Yeah?
Yeah, if you have an infinite
number of processors,
you have P.
so if you could do it in a
certain amount of time with P,
you can certainly do it in that
time with an infinite number of
processors.
OK, this is in this model
where, you know,
there is lots of stuff that
this model doesn't model like
communication costs and
interference,
and all sorts of things.
But it is simple model,
which actually in practice
works out pretty well,
OK, you're not going to be able
to do more work with P
processors than you are with an
infinite number of processors.
OK, so those are helpful bounds
to understand when we are trying
to make something go faster,
it's nice to know what you
could possibly hope to achieve,
OK, as opposed to beating your
head against a wall,
how come I can't get it to go
much faster?
Maybe it's because one of these
lower bounds is operating.
OK, well, we're interested in
how fast we can go.
That's the main reason for
using multiple processors is you
hope you're going to go faster
than you could with one
processor.
So, we define T_1 over T_P to
be the speedup on P processors.
OK, so we say,
how much faster is it on P
processors than on one
processor?
OK, that's the speed up.
If T_1 over T_P is order P,
we say that it's linear
speedup.
OK, in other words,
why?
Because that says that it means
that if I've thrown P processors
at the job I'm going to get a
speedup that's proportional to
P.
OK, so when I throw P
processors at the job and I get
T_P, if that's order P,
that means that in some sense
my processors each contributed
within a constant factor its
full measure of support.
If this, in fact,
were equal to P,
we'd call that perfect linear
speedup.
OK, so but here we're looking
at giving ourselves,
for theoretical purposes,
a little bit of a constant
buffer here, perhaps.
If T_1 over T_P is greater than
P, we call that super linear
speedup.
OK, so can somebody tell me,
when can I get super linear
speedup?
When can I get super linear
speed up?
Never.
OK, why never?
Yeah, if we buy these lower
bounds, the first lower bound
there, it is T_P is greater than
or equal to T_1 over P.
And, if I just take T_1 over
T_P, that says it's less than or
equal to P.
so, this is never,
OK, not possible in this model.
OK, there are other models
where it is possible to get
super linear speed up due to
caching effects,
and things of that nature.
But in this simple model that
we are dealing with,
it's not possible to get super
linear speedup.
OK, not possible.
Now, the maximum possible
speedup, given some amount of
work and critical path length is
what?
What's the maximum possible
speed up I could get over any
number of processors?
What's the maximum I could
possibly get?
No, I'm saying,
no matter how many processors,
what's the most speedup that I
could get?
T_1 over T infinity,
because this is the,
so T_1 over T infinity is the
maximum I could possibly get.
OK, if I threw an infinite
number of processors at the
problem, that's going to give me
my biggest speedup.
OK, and we call that the
parallelism.
OK, so that's defined to be the
So the parallelism of the
particular algorithm is
essentially the work divided by
the critical path length.
Another way of viewing it is
that this is the average amount
of work that can be done in
parallel along each step of the
critical path.
And, we denote it often by P
bar.
So, do not get confused.
P bar does not have anything to
do with P at some level.
OK, P is going to be a certain
number of processors you're
running.
P bar is defined just in terms
of the computation you're
executing, not in terms of the
machine you're running it on.
OK, it's just the average
amount of work that can be done
in parallel along each step of
the critical path.
OK, questions so far?
So mostly we're just doing
definitions so far.
OK, now we get into,
OK, so it's helpful to know
what the parallelism is,
because the parallelism is
going to, there's no real point
in trying to get speed up bigger
than the parallelism.
OK, so if you are given a
particular computation,
you'll be able to say,
oh, it doesn't go any faster.
You're throwing more processors
at it.
Why is it that going any
faster?
And the answer could be,
no more parallelism.
OK, let's see what I want to,
yeah, I think we can raise the
example here.
We'll talk more about this
model.
Mostly, now,
we're going to just talk about
DAG's.
So, we'll talk about the
programming model next time.
So, let's talk about
scheduling.
The goal of scheduler is to map
the computation to P processors.
And this is typically done by a
runtime system,
which, if you will,
is an algorithm that is running
underneath the language layer
that I showed you.
OK, so the programmer designs
an algorithm using spawns,
and syncs, and so forth.
Then, underneath that,
there's an algorithm that has
to actually map that executing
program onto the processors of
the machine as it executes.
And that's the scheduler.
OK, so it's done by the
language runtime system,
typically.
OK, so it turns out that online
schedulers, let me just say
they're complex.
OK, they're not necessarily
easy things to build.
OK, they're not too bad
actually.
But, we are not going to go
there because we only have two
lectures to do this.
Instead, we're going to do is
we'll illustrate the ideas using
off-line scheduling.
OK, so you'll get an idea out
of this for what a scheduler
does, and it turns out that
doing these things online is
another level of complexity
beyond that.
And typically,
the online schedulers that are
good, these days,
are randomized schedulers.
And they have very strong
proofs of their ability to
perform.
But we're not going to go
there.
We'll keep it simple.
And in particular,
we're going to look at a
particular type of scheduler
called a greedy scheduler.
So, if you have a DAG to
execute, so the basic rules of
the scheduler is you can't
execute a node until all of the
nodes that precede it in the DAG
have executed.
OK, so you've got to wait until
everything is executed.
So, a greedy scheduler,
what it says is let's just try
to do as much as possible on
every step, OK?
In other words,
it says I'm never going to try
to guess that it's worthwhile
delaying doing something.
If I could do something now,
I'm going to do it.
And so, each step is going to
correspond to be one of two
types.
The first type is what we'll
call a complete step.
And this is a step in which
there are at least P threads
ready to run.
And, I'm executing on P
processors.
There are at least P threads
ready to run.
So, what's a greedy strategy
here?
I've got P processors.
I've got at least P threads.
Run any P.
Yeah, first P would be if you
had a notion of ordering.
That would be perfectly
reasonable.
Here, we are just going to
execute any P.
We might make a mistake there,
because there may be a
particular one that if we
execute now, that'll enable more
parallelism later on.
We might not execute that one.
We don't know.
OK, but basically,
what we're going to do is just
execute any P willy-nilly.
So, there's some,
if you will,
non-determinism in this step
here because which one you
execute may or may not be a good
choice.
OK, the second type of step
we're going to have is an
incomplete step.
And this is a situation where
we have fewer than P threads
ready to run.
So, what's our strategy there?
Execute all of them.
OK, if it's greedy,
no point in not executing.
OK, so if I've got more than P
threads ready to run,
I execute any P.
If I have fewer than P threads
ready to run,
we execute all of them.
So, it turns out this is a good
strategy.
It's not a perfect strategy.
In fact, the strategy of trying
to schedule optimally a DAG on P
processors is NP complete,
meaning it's very difficult.
So, those of you going to take
6.045 or 6.840,
I highly recommend these
courses, and we'll talk more
about that in the last lecture
as we talked a little bit about
what's coming up in the theory
engineering concentration.
You can learn about NP
completeness and about how you
show that certain problems,
there are no good algorithms
for them, OK,
that we are aware of,
OK, and what exactly that
means.
So, it turns out that this type
of scheduling problem turns out
to be a very difficult problem
to get it optimal.
But, there's nice theorem,
due independently to Graham and
Brent.
It says, essentially,
a greedy scheduler executes any
computation,
G, with work,
T_1, and critical path length,
T infinity in time,
T_P, less than or equal to T_1
over P plus T infinity --
-- on a computer with P
processors.
OK, so, it says that I can
achieve T_1 over P plus T
infinity.
So, what does that say?
If we take a look and compare
this with our lower bounds on
runtime, how efficient is this?
How does this compare with the
optimal execution?
Yeah, it's two competitive.
It's within a factor of two of
optimal because this is a lower
bound and this is a lower bound.
And so, if I take twice the max
of these two,
twice the maximum of these two,
that's going to be bigger than
the sum.
So, I'm within a factor of two
of which ever is the stronger,
lower bound for any situation.
So, this says you get within a
factor of two of efficiency of
scheduling in terms of the
runtime on P processors.
OK, does everybody see that?
So, let's prove this theorem.
It's quite an elegant theorem.
It's not a hard theorem.
One of the nice things,
by the way, about this week,
is that nothing is very hard.
It just requires you to think
differently.
OK, so the proof has to do with
counting up how many complete
steps we have,
and how many incomplete steps
we have.
OK, so we'll start with the
number of complete steps.
So, can somebody tell me what's
the largest number of complete
steps I could possibly have?
Yeah, I heard somebody mumble
it back there.
T_1 over P.
Why is that?
Yeah, so the number of complete
steps is, at most,
T_1 over P because why?
Yeah, once you've had this
many, you've done T_1 work,
OK?
So, every complete step I'm
getting P work done.
So, if I did more than T_1 over
P steps, there would be no more
work to be done.
So, the number of complete
steps can't be bigger than T_1
over P.
OK, so that's this piece.
OK, now we're going to count up
the incomplete steps,
and show its bounded by T
infinity.
OK, so let's consider an
incomplete step.
And, let's see what happens.
And, let's let G prime be the
subgraph of G that remains to be
executed.
OK, so we'll draw a picture
here.
So, imagine we have,
let's draw it on a new board.
So here, we're going to have a
graph, our graph,
G.
We're going to do actually P
equals three as our example
here.
So, imagine that this is the
graph, G.
And, I'm not showing the
procedures here because this
actually is a theorem that works
for any DAG.
And, the procedure outlines are
not necessary.
All we care about is the
threads.
I missed one.
OK, so imagine that's my DAG,
G, and imagine that I have
executed up to this point.
Which ones have I executed?
Yeah, I've executed these guys.
So, the things that are in G
prime are just the things that
have yet to be executed.
And these guys are the ones
that are already executed.
And, we'll imagine that all of
them are unit time threads
without loss of generality.
The theorem would go through,
even if each of these had a
particular time associated with
it.
The same scheduling algorithm
will work just fine.
So, how can I characterize the
threads that are ready to be
executed?
Which are the threads that are
ready to be executed here?
Let's just see.
So, that one?
No, that's not ready to be
executed.
Why?
Because it's got a predecessor
here, this guy.
OK, so this guy is ready to be
executed, and this guy is ready
to be executed.
OK, so those two threads are
ready to be, how can I
characterize this?
What's their property?
What's a graph theoretic
property in G prime that tells
me whether or not something is
ready to be executed?
It has no predecessor,
but what's another way of
saying that?
It's got no predecessor in G
prime.
What does it mean for a node
not to have a predecessor in a
graph?
Its in degree is zero,
right?
Same thing.
OK, the threads with in degree,
zero and G prime are the ones
that are ready to be executed.
OK, and if it's incomplete
step, what do I do?
I'm going to execute says,
if it's an incomplete step,
I execute all of them.
OK, so I execute all of these.
OK, now I execute all of the in
degree zero threads,
what happens to the critical
path length of the graph that
remains to be executed?
It decreases by one.
OK, so the critical path length
of what remains to be executed,
G prime, is reduced by one.
So, what's left to be executed
on every incomplete step,
what's left to be executed
always reduces by one.
Notice the next step here is
going to be a complete step,
because I've got four things
that are ready to go.
And, I can execute them in such
a way that the critical path
length doesn't get reduced on
that step.
OK, but if I had to execute all
of them, then it does reduce the
critical path length.
Now, of course,
both could happen,
OK, at the same time,
OK, but any time that I have an
incomplete step,
I'm guaranteed to reduce the
critical path length by one.
OK, so that implies that the
number of incomplete steps is,
at most, T infinity.
And so, therefore,
T of P is, at most,
the number of complete steps
plus the number of incomplete
steps.
And we get our bound.
This is sort of an amortized
argument if you want to think of
it that way, OK,
that at every step I'm either
amortizing the step against the
work, or I'm amortizing it
against the critical path
length, or possibly both.
But I'm at least doing one of
those for every step,
OK, and so, in the end,
I just have to add up the two
contributions.
Any questions about that?
So this, by the way,
is the fundamental theorem of
all scheduling.
If ever you study anything
having to do with scheduling,
this basic result is sort of
the foundation of a huge number
of things.
And then what people do is they
gussy it up, like,
let's do this online,
OK, with a scheduler,
etc., that everybody's trying
to match these bounds,
OK, of what an omniscient
greedy scheduler would achieve,
OK, and there are all kinds of
other things.
But this is sort of the basic
theorem that just pervades the
whole area of scheduling.
OK, let's do a quick corollary.
I'm not going to erase those.
Those are just too important.
I want to erase those.
Let's not erase those.
I want to erase that either.
We're going to go back to the
top.
Actually, we'll put the
corollary here because that's
just one line.
OK.
The corollary says you get
linear speed up if the number of
processors that you allocate,
that you run your job on is
order, the parallelism.
OK, so greedy scheduler gives
you linear speed up if you're
running on essentially
parallelism or fewer processors.
OK, so let's see why that is.
And I hope I'll fit this,
OK?
So, P bar is T_1 over T
infinity.
And that implies that if P
equals order T_1 over T
infinity, then that says just
bringing those around,
T infinity is order T_1 over P.
So, everybody with me?
It's just algebra.
So, it says this is the
definition of parallelism,
T_1 over T infinity,
and so, if P is order
parallelism, then it's order T_1
over T infinity.
And now, just bring it around.
It says T infinity is order T_1
over P.
So, that says T infinity is
order T_1 over P.
OK, and so, therefore,
continue the proof here,
thus T_P is at most T_1 over P
plus T infinity.
Well, if this is order T_1 over
P, the whole thing is order T_1
over P.
OK, and so, now I have T_P is
order T_1 over P,
and what we need is to compute
T_1 over T_P,
and that's going to be order
T_P.
OK?
Does everybody see that?
So what that says is that if I
have a certain amount of
parallelism, if I run
essentially on fewer processors
than that parallelism,
I get linear speed up if I use
greedy scheduling.
OK, if I run on more processors
than the parallelism,
in some sense I'm being
wasteful because I can't
possibly get enough speed up to
justify those extra processors.
So, understanding parallelism
of a job says that's sort of a
limit on the number of
processors I want to have.
And, in fact,
I can achieve that.
Question?
Yeah, really,
in some sense,
this is saying it should be
omega P.
Yeah, so that's fine.
It's a question of,
so ask again.
No, no, it's only if it's
bounded above by a constant.
T_1 and T infinity aren't
constants.
They're variables in this.
So, we are doing multivariable
asymptotic analysis.
So, any of these things can be
a function of anything else,
and can be growing as much as
we want.
So, the fact that we say we are
given it for a particular thing,
we're really not given that
number.
We're given a whole class of
DAG's or whatever of various
sizes is really what we're
talking about.
So, I can look at the growth.
Here, where it's talking about
the growth of the parallelism,
sorry, the growth of the
runtime T_P as a function of T_1
and T infinity.
So, I am talking about things
that are growing here,
OK?
OK, so let's put this to work,
And, in fact,
so now I'm going to go back to
here.
Now I'm going to tell you about
a little bit of my own research,
and how we use this in some of
the work that we did.
OK, so we've developed a
dynamic multithreaded language
called Cilk, spelled with a C
because it's based on the
language, C.
And, it's not an acronym
because silk is like nice
threads, OK, although at one
point my students had a
competition for what the acronym
silk could mean.
The winner, turns out,
was Charles' Idiotic Linguistic
Kluge.
So anyway, if you want to take
a look at it,
you can find some stuff on it
here.
OK,
OK, and what it uses is
actually one of these more
complicated schedulers.
It's a randomized online
scheduler, OK,
and if you look at its expected
runtime on P processors,
it gets effectively T_1 over P
plus O of T infinity provably.
OK, and empirically,
if you actually look at what
kind of runtimes you get to find
out what's hidden in the big O
there, it turns out,
in fact, it's T_1 over P plus T
infinity with the constants here
being very close to one
empirically.
So, no guarantees,
but this turns out to be a
pretty good bound.
Sometimes, you see a
coefficient on T infinity that's
up maybe close to four or
something.
But generally,
you don't see something that's
much bigger than that.
And mostly, it tends to be
around, if you do a linear
regression curve fit,
you get that the constant here
is close to one.
And so, with this,
you get near perfect if you use
this formula as a model for your
runtime.
You get near perfect linear
speed up if the number of
processors you're running on is
much less than your average
parallelism, which,
of course, is the same thing as
if T infinity is much less than
T_1 over P.
So, what happens here is that
when P is much less than P
infinity, that is,
T infinity is much less than
T_1 over P, this term ceases to
matter very much,
and you get very good speedup,
OK, in fact,
almost perfect speedup.
So, each processor gives you
another processor's work as long
as you are the range where the
number of processors is much
less than the number of
parallelism.
Now, with this language many
years ago, which seems now like
many years ago,
OK, it turned out we competed.
We built a bunch of chess
programs.
And, among our programs were
Starsocrates,
and Cilkchess,
and we also had several others.
And these were,
I would call them,
world-class.
In particular,
we tied for first in the 1995
World Computer Chess
Championship in Hong Kong,
and then we had a playoff and
we lost.
It was really a shame.
We almost won,
running on a big parallel
machine.
That was, incidentally,
some of you may know about the
Deep Blue chess playing program.
That was the last time before
they faced then world champion
Kasparov that they competed
against programs.
They tied for third in that
tournament.
OK, so we actually out-placed
them.
However, in the head-to-head
competition, we lost to them.
So we had one loss in the
tournament up to the point of
the finals.
They had a loss and a draw.
Most people aren't aware that
Deep Blue, in fact,
was not the reigning World
Computer Chess Championship when
they faced Kasparov.
The reason that they faced
Kasparov was because IBM was
willing to put up the money.
OK, so we developed these chess
programs, and the way we
developed them,
let me in particular talk about
Starsocrates.
We had this interesting anomaly
come up.
We were running on a 32
processor computer at MIT for
development.
And, we had access to a 512
processor computer for the
tournament at NCSA at the
University of Illinois.
So, we had this big machine.
Of course, they didn't want to
give it to us very much,
but we have the same machine,
just a small one,
at MIT.
So, we would develop on this,
and occasionally we'd be able
to run on this,
and this was what we were
developing for on our processor.
So, let me show you sort of the
anomaly that came up,
OK?
So, we had a version of a
program that I'll call the
original program,
OK, and we had an optimized
program that included some new
features that were supposed to
make the program go faster.
And so, we timed it on our 32
processor machine.
And, it took us 65 seconds to
run it.
OK, and then we timed this new
program.
So, I'll call that T prime of
sub 32 on our 32 processor
machine, and it ran and 40
seconds to do this particular
benchmark.
Now, let me just say,
I've lied about the actual
numbers here to make the
calculations easy.
But, the same idea happened.
Just the numbers were messier.
OK, so this looks like a
significant improvement in
runtime, but we rejected the
optimization.
OK, and the reason we rejected
it is because we understood
about the issues of work and
critical path.
So, let me show you the
analysis that we did,
OK?
So the analysis,
it turns out,
if we looked at our
instrumentation,
the work in this case was
2,048.
And, the critical path was one
second, which,
over here with the optimized
program, the work was,
in fact, 1,024.
But the critical path was
eight.
So, if we plug into our simple
model here, the one I have up
there with the approximation
there, I have T_32 is equal to
T_1 over 32 plus T infinity,
and that's equal to,
well, the work is 2,048 divided
by 32.
What's that?
64, good, plus the critical
path, one, that's 65.
So, that checks out with what
we saw.
OK, in fact,
we did that,
and it checked out.
OK, it was very close.
OK, over here,
T prime of 32 is T prime,
one over 32 plus T infinity
prime, and that's equal to 1,024
divided by 32 is 32 plus eight,
the critical path here.
That's 40.
So, that checked out too.
So, now what we did is we said
is we said, OK,
let's extrapolate to our big
machine.
How fast are these things going
to run on our big machine?
Well, for that,
we want T of 512.
And, that's equal to T_1 over
512 plus T infinity.
And so, what's 2,048 divided by
512?
It's four, plus T infinity is
one.
That's equal to five.
So, go quite a bit faster on
this.
But here, T prime of 512 is
equal to T one prime over 512
plus T infinity prime is equal
to, well, 1,024 plus divided by
512 is two plus critical path of
eight, that's ten.
OK, and so, you see that on the
big machine, we would have been
running twice as slow had we
adopted that,
quote, "optimization",
OK, because we had run out of
parallelism, and this was making
the path longer.
We needed to have a way of
doing it where we could reduce
the work.
Yeah, it's good to reduce the
work but not as the critical
path ends up getting rid of the
parallels that we hope to be
able to use during the runtime.
So, it's twice as slow,
OK, twice as slow.
So the moral is that the work
and critical path length predict
the performance better than the
execution time alone,
OK, when you look at
scalability.
And a big issue on a lot of
these machines is scalability;
not always, sometimes you're
not worried about scalability.
Sometimes you just care.
Had we been running in the
competition on a 32 processor
machine, we would have accepted
this optimization.
It would have been a good
trade-off.
OK, but because we knew that we
were running on a machine with a
lot more processors,
and that we were close to
running out of the parallelism,
it didn't make sense to be
increasing the critical path at
that point, because that was
just reducing the parallelism of
our calculation.
OK, next time,
any questions about that first?
No?
OK.
Next time, now that we
understand the model for
execution, we're going to start
looking at the performance of
particular algorithms what we
code them up in a dynamic,
multithreaded style,
OK?